[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the time has come we've worked so hard
for this and put in so many hours to get
to this moment it's finally here the
Game of Thrones finale 9 p.m. HBO see
you there
seniors congratulations and welcome to
bath day we are your senior class
officers I'm Julia I'm Jen yes and I'm
Rebecca we've had a great year plenty
events as chairs of the senior class
Council thanks to thanks to our
dedicated team we are able to have
events that brought our class together
during our final year at Yale our
classmates showed up to all our events
ready to go but let's not forget some
things that actually happened behind the
scenes like remember at the time when
Rebecca our very fiscally responsible
treasurer bought 10 extra kegs for
Oktoberfest event solely for peace of
mind even Dean Chen asked what are you
gonna do with all his leftover beer
don't worry Dean Shawn we figured out a
solution during our time here at Yale we
have witnessed many changes as a class
wait let's unpack that on our very first
day at Yale we showed up as bright-eyed
first year's
fresh out of high school fully prepared
with our notebooks and I in our lanyards
in hand
fast forward to senior year and our
first day look was no backpack no sleep
and checking the location of our classes
right as we were watching to them we
went from having camp yell friends to
real friends and while we lost and while
we lost sasha pub we gained a new
handsome Dan our class finally broke the
harvard-yale losing streak Reese Kermes
both the Yale Bowl and Harvard Stadium
and took selfies with presidents a lavae
who seemed to love beating Harvard even
more than we did when we came in we
fought the 12 college challenge was hard
guess what the 14 college challenge is
even harder as we reflect on our time
here at Yale we realized that there are
some things we just probably won't mess
like hearing presidential colleges are
microcosm of the Yale community for
realizing you're having a very bad night
when you're forced to move from sterling
to bass library at 11:45 p.m. and then
you've got to go back to your twin XL
bed which is never fun especially when
you're six three I know I won't miss
struggling to open every gate at Yale
why are they so heavy
and then there's always midterm season
which essentially means the entire
semester
well we won't miss the library shifts or
the massive gates there's so much of
Yale we will miss like the spontaneity
of college and living a block away from
your closest friends where the people
that make the day-to-day moments really
fun and are the reason why we love Yale
nowhere do I feel more connected to my
class then Wednesdays at 1:00 a.m. when
we all chant live in on a prayer
together we won't miss the days when the
temperature actually gets above freezing
and Yale looks like the brochure we
crawl out of hibernation I'll sit on
cross campus and pretend to do work I
will miss our Yale late nights when we
go to the buttery to grab a one dollar
quesadilla orcid ng have eating a bacon
egg and cheese with our friends we also
appreciate the person we happen to me
through a class club or team corn
expectedly became one of our closest
friends I know I can say that about the
two people right here with me on stage
we are grateful that Yale allowed us to
understand the people we want to be in
an open and accepting environment we're
able to express ourselves and share our
own experiences although at times Yale
was challenging we had family friends
and faculty who helped us make it
through we'd like to take the time now
to thank you all
today we celebrate what we have achieved
tomorrow
we look forward to new possibilities
congratulations to us all which would be
so proud of ourselves for making it to
this day hello class of 2019 I'm Shirley
and I'm Harold we are members of this
year's class a planning committee you
will meet all the rest of the members
throughout this afternoon's ceremony but
for now we have the honor of introducing
our class a speaker so we have with us
today an acclaimed writer and inspiring
global citizen whose words teaching and
social activism have had an indelible
impact on the Diaspora and brought our
contemporary culture she's known for her
award-winning novels nonfiction
her ribbon and TED Talks and much more
she was born in Nigeria where her father
was a professor and her mother was the
first female registrar he studied
medicine for a year Adam suka then left
for the United States at the age of 19
to continue her education on a different
path she graduated summa [ __ ] laude from
Eastern Connecticut State University
with a degree in communication and
political science she also has a
master's degree in creative writing from
Johns Hopkins University and a Master of
Arts in African history from Yale
her work has been translated into over
30 languages and her novels have won
prestigious prizes in literature her
2013 novel Americana who owned the US
National Book Critics Circle Award and
was named one of the New York Times top
10 best books of 2013 in 2008 she
received a MacArthur Genius grant
fellowship and in 2015 she was named one
of Time Magazine's 100 most influential
people in the world so in her literary
and oratory work she warns against a
danger of a single story the idea that
people living in certain parts of the
world all have one kind of experience
and she reminds us to always seek the
truth as a Nigerian American myself I
can say without a doubt that her work
has inspired cross generational
communication about the history and
tragedies that have shaped the lived
experiences of millions through her
writing speeches and activist work she
brings light to the many sacrifices that
members of the Diaspora like my parents
make in hopes of a brighter future her
narratives of love grit and diversity
give a voice to the voiceless and power
to those who have often been overlooked
by history today with the utmost honor
we introduce to you our 2019 Yale class
day speaker Amanda Garvey
thank you for the warm welcome I'm just
love congratulations graduates in class
of 2019 so last year the class this
speaker was Hillary Rodham Clinton this
year you got me so and so I want to
start by telling you how sorry I am
and by the way considering the last
three years I imagine it must have been
refreshing for last year's class to hear
from a politician who is an actual adult
[Applause]
to hear from a person who is a ticklish
experienced thoughtful literate measured
and with an adult's vocabulary it's been
ten years since I was here in graduate
school I wasn't always happy here for
reasons having to do more with me than
with Yale so it wasn't a lit was me but
I wouldn't change any of it
it's good to be back and to be reminded
of spending hours in articles bookstore
and getting dinner at the Indian
restaurant that my husband and I loved
and attending seminars in professor
Thompson's house which was full of
objects that he collected in central
Africa in the 1960s and there was also
the slightly awkward seminar I took on
African literature in which my own novel
was part of the curriculum
I just sat there and said nothing and I
wasn't sure what to do with my face but
most importantly being here Yale
afforded me many opportunities to engage
in that activity that is essential for a
fiction writer eavesdropping I did it in
the library in the gym by walking a
little too close to people in the
hallways and for a writer almost nothing
is out of bounds if it leads to
collecting material for fiction and Yale
having such a wide range of interesting
people I mean just look at your hats the
material I collected here was absolute
gold thank you so much
I'm very honored and very happy to be
your class day speaker thank you for
inviting me I know you're all excited to
be graduating and while I congratulate
you I also want you to know that it only
goes downhill from here when I graduated
from undergrad I felt on board the
structure of expectations was gone no
more classes to attend no more papers to
write and the world felt wide open
disorienting dizzying I was full of
contradictions and I was in a battle
with myself about my contradictions
because I did not know then that it is
human and okay to have contradictions I
was full of uncertainty and I did not
know that confidence is a journey a
continuous journey and not an absolute
destination and I want to tell you this
now to save you years of figuring it out
yourself there are days when you will be
bursting with certainty
and days when you will be flattened by
doubts and it helps a little to keep in
mind how universal this is there are so
many things I said I would never do when
I was younger and I now do many of them
I would give you detailed examples but I
don't want to unnecessarily alarm you
the point is be open to changing your
mind
it is often a sign of growth be open to
the possibility that you might be wrong
ideology is a good thing but if you find
that you heal unquestioningly to every
orthodoxy of the ideology you subscribe
to then maybe it's time for some agility
in your thinking a small shift for
example a sign that shows that you know
that they're complicated shades of grey
everywhere I would suggest in general
that you marry being idealistic with
being pragmatic and it helps to think of
Puritanism as too expensive as something
you cannot afford so politics is awful
in all sorts of ways but refusing to
participate is not the answer sometimes
you have to get in there to be able to
walk to what's changing it to what you
want it to be engage with the wall
that's as it is otherwise you won't
really get anything done but as you do
so it is important to have as your
guiding light a clear vision of what the
world should be I think of my writing as
my vocation it is what I am on earth to
do
but there are people who know me not for
my writing but for my speaking about
feminism
I did not set out to be a feminist icon
and I'm still hoping that somebody will
make me a hat that says feminist icon I
happened to have a platform from my
rights in and I happen to feel strongly
about justice in general but the
Equality of women in particular and I
began to use that platform to talk about
what mattered to me and it happened to
resonate with people who already were
thinking about the same things it also
happened to irritate quite a few people
I remember a man who spent a lot of time
trying to explain to me why his wife
always had to submit to him I was a bit
confused about why anybody would be so
insistent on the idea that the rightful
place for a fellow human being was a
place of permanent subjugation why would
a well-balanced person need another
person to submit the world is full of
people like that man
is it necessarily my responsibility to
educate them know do I want to yes why
because I think it's worthwhile to give
people most people the benefit of the
doubt because I think it's worth trying
to change a person's mind if that would
lead to a greater human good and because
full disclosure I happen to have a mild
case of a Messiah Complex I want to
change a small slice of the world so
while trying to get a man to see the
full humanity of women mean that he
might for example stop justifying
domestic abuse
maybe maybe not but I want to try I see
it as trying to walk towards making a
small slice of the kind of world I want
to live in I have a dear friend who
lives in Lagos
her name is bossy she's an utterly
brilliant and humane gynecologist and
she has a daughter who clearly inherited
her mother's genes this daughter grew up
in Nigeria and was then sent to private
secondary school in the UK she excelled
and she was a top of her class in every
subject and so they were recently
thinking about where she would go to
university and because I deeply admire
the American liberal arts curriculum I
told her that I thought she would
benefit from going to university in the
US rather than the UK her response in a
very calm
sixteen-year-old voice was I don't want
to go to America because I don't want to
die the starkness the directness of her
wards threw me off for a moment
obviously she meant guns her mother
later told me that she had been
particularly scarred by the video of a
white policeman shooting a black man in
the back there is a figurative ebo
expression for a certain kind of unease
a disruption a troubled Ness that
expression is if a marrow pool and it
translates literally to things are not
standing well the awkward beauty of this
expression things are not standing well
best captures my sense of America today
to say that things are falling up
Oh half fallen apart might sound as
though one is susceptible to
melodramatic exaggeration but things are
not standing well wherever you might be
on the ideological spectrum things are
not standing well if fear is in the air
that Americans breathe I bring this up
because I want to suggest that as you
graduate in this time that you ask
yourself the question what should
America be should America be a country
where fear is always an option for
children in school where a child can go
to school and never come home because
that child has been murdered by another
child with a gun should America be a
country where black people live in fear
of their lives because members of the
police do not seem to think of them as
full human beings should America be a
country where women are in fear of not
having full autonomy over their bodies
is a country still a full democracy if
fear is in the air its citizens breathe
should America be a country of Patriots
people inspired by love and pride or
should it be a country of nationalists
people inspired by hatred of enemies
many of those enemies real and many more
invented what should America be
conceptualized that America and then
make the case for that America not only
in obvious ways such as how you vote but
also in smaller ways how you treat other
people how you think of other people the
things you refuse to condone
the people whose grievances you refuse
to dismiss the acts of kindness you do
the people you choose to listen to and
to hear and truly hearing people can
often be the best way of showing them
that they matter so going by historical
precedent a Yale degree makes you more
likely than the average graduate to
become president or a senator or a
Supreme Court judge a Yale degree makes
you more likely to become a person who
in different capacities will be
responsible for policies and actions
that will affect the lives of millions
of people no pressure
by the way this is proof if we ever
needed proof of how fair America's
unimpeachable meritocracy is not the
point though is that a Yale degree will
open doors there are people who will
resent you for having a Yale degree but
there are many more people who will
accord you the automatic assumption of
competence if your degree does end up
propelling you to power remember that if
power were a jacket it is most
flattering on all body types when worn
very lightly if you end up working in a
non-profit remember that the best
charity is that which does not
perpetuate itself never forget that
human beings actual human beings with
dreams and hopes and fears with pride
and favorite foods and things they
dislike unlike are the focus of your
charity numbers
six language can sometimes make the real
humanity of people invisible and
sometimes people you expect to be
grateful for your charity will not be at
least not in the way you want or expect
because it can be complicated to be the
recipients of charity if your job
involves travelling around the world
remember that local knowledge is always
best yes read the country reports
written by the CIA or whoever writes
those reports but place a higher value
on local knowledge local newspapers
literature the person who picks you up
from the airport and if you are one day
and robed in corporate power and some of
you here certainly will be please hire
women as executives are not just in
human relations
change corporate culture have an on-site
daycare make paid family leave standard
ordinary if you find yourself with power
in the world of journalism banished
forever the practice of false
equivalence journalism should be about
the truth not about balance if you're
reporting on the facts that climate
change exists you don't need to bring in
a hack to show the other side because
there is no other side and if you do
become a journalist please learn how to
say I'm sorry
journalism seems to be a profession
whose practitioners have great
difficulty in saying I'm sorry
without hedging or equivocating and
speaking of saying sorry knowing how to
say I'm sorry and mean I'm sorry will
serve you well no matter what costs your
life takes and if you are one of those
people whose tongues seem unable unable
to form those words I'm sorry there is
hope practicing in front of a mirror
helps don't change the subject
don't pretend that nothing happened
don't buy a gift and deflect don't ride
it out in silence hoping it will go away
just say I'm sorry a few times if
necessary and of course it helps if you
actually mean it but please do not ever
apologize for existing or for taking up
space in the world or for having a
well-considered
opinion and I say this particularly to
women who's socialization teaches them
teaches us to shrink ourselves as though
our responsibility is never first
to ourselves but always to others and we
end up sometimes feeling guilty for
wanting the things we want for wanting
to be our own selves first the messages
that society sends us can be conflicting
that tension between telling you to
value yourself that you matter and then
that other message that tells you to put
other people first and to serve it is
possible it is necessary that you find a
balance between the two but you will
have to figure it out yourself but if I
can offer a useful guiding principle it
is this you do not have to make room in
your life for people who wish you harm
so one enduring lesson I learned here at
Yale is always to look at primary
sources first and I've held on to that
lesson it is I think a useful lesson
especially in this age of easy outrage
when so many people are quick to react
to an isolated port or sometimes
received second or third hand so I once
read a book review and based on that
review I decided not to read the book
because it didn't sound like my sort of
thing many years later I read the book
because I was at a writing retreat and
it was sitting there on a shelf and I
thought I would just read one page and
then I couldn't stop I loved it and I
could not believe how that reviewer
could have so mischaracterized that book
so if you choose to participate in the
cult of the outrage of the day on social
media and if you're quick to jump in
with your blistering take and I
understand that the adrenaline boost
can be addictive but before you jump in
the fray look up primary sources first
and remember that context is always
Queen this is also I think a good way of
testing your own beliefs take a little
time to find out what was actually said
or done and if you have context then
maybe maybe you might just start to
question what you thought you knew
having said that I do sometimes worry
that American education has created a
class of brilliant talented people but
people who are nonetheless afraid to say
the wrong thing
even in ostensibly safe spaces if the
walled inside of college was safe then
you should know that the world outside
of college is not and I urge you always
always to honor the doubts that you have
are not the questions that you have
don't silence yourself so I want to tell
you about a conversation that happened
among a group of people recently people
who were acquaintances if not friends
but who all generally were on the same
side and I might or might not have been
eavesdropping on their conversation so
they were talking about a politician and
one of them said that the politician was
a racist because that politician
supported school choice another one then
asked tentatively but how and the
response from everyone else in this
group was a lot of eye rolling a lot of
sneering and then finally one person
gave a treatise on how supporting this
politician was just supporting racism at
the end
nobody had explained why support in
school choice was horrible and there is
a valid argument to be made for that
position but this young person was left
not knowing what that argument was and
perhaps also left feeling heavier with
several layers of shame I worry that the
space is occupied by the educated in
this country have become places where
curiosity is considered passe it is now
an environment where everyone is already
supposed to know supposed to get it and
those who don't as seen as morally
lacking if there is a lesson here it is
that you should always remember that a
self-righteous sneer is not an argument
don't be that person who attacks or
demeans because you are unable to
convince I know that the idea of
bringing receipts is a thing in your
generation it would have been nice if
someone in that group had brought
receipts make the argument clarify
explain do the walk cite statistics if
you need to and bring the damn receipts
when I started out writing I was doing
what I loved what gave me the greatest
joy and I hoped also to be read and
today I feel grateful to be read to be
taken seriously to be here my walk is
very important to me it's central to my
life but the moments of greatest joy for
me are not necessarily those that have
to do with my success and so please not
sure your ambitions seek to be
successful but keep in mind that there
are hollows that success will not feel
and yes this is where I talk about love
I have a Swiss friend who once lived in
DC but now lives in Zurich
and I asked him what he had made of
America when he lived here and he said
Americans don't have friends because
they are too busy working he meant I
think people who live in America whether
citizens or not and so I urge you class
of 2019 to prove him wrong have friends
many friends or just one friend hold
your family close and family doesn't
necessarily mean those to whom you're
related by blood or by social
institution hold your friends clues
stand up for your loved ones tell the
people you love that you love them tell
them often find reasons to laugh
gravitate towards people with whom you
never feel that pressure to perform or
to be what you're not one of the tenets
I try to live by is never admire quietly
if I admire something about someone I
let them know we do not always recognize
what is beautiful in ourselves in our
spirits until somebody has pointed it
out to us and remember that people will
hardly ever forget small acts of
kindness
I remember once during a public event I
was exhausted I was a little grumpy
actually I was very grumpy and I was
surrounded by people none of whom seemed
to see my exhaustion and then my friend
and then my friend Sheila who was there
sort of looked at me and said she's
tired and I almost burst into tears
because I felt so wonderfully seen be
kind paying attention is one of the most
beautiful acts of kindness the people
you will come across in your life will
not forget when you are kind and they
will not forget when you're unkind I
wish you well as you go out into the
world I wish you courage I wish you joy
and of on a final note as you navigate
the world it might be helpful from time
to time to forget that you went to Yale
congratulations
[Applause]
on behalf of Yale College I wanted to
thank you again for being the primary
source of your wisdom intellect and
inspiration
thank you for your Messiah spirit you
are read you are heard you are seeing
you are loved
thank you okay so we have a little
exercise to do here with all the seniors
but first I want to ask the following
students to come up to the seats over
here in the front row right in the
baking Sun for so please come up when I
call your name Jude alrahman Aloha of
Branford College Hanna Lawrence of
Davenport College
Andrea Masterson of Jonathan Edwards
college Lily Murr Fakhri of Davenport
College the Ren or Bay of Jonathan
Edwards College ache a pain of Berkeley
College
elana pike of timothy dwight college
[Applause]
Devyn Christine Rigsby of Pierson
college and Simon Whiteman of Trumbull
college all right so a seniors we're
gonna do a little dress rehearsal for
tomorrow the main commencement event
here I'll be up on this stage where I'll
be kind of standing right there facing
presidents a Levay and I will be
presenting you all to him so that you
can receive your degrees I'll be saying
a few words of the last two sentences of
my requests are going to be like this
they have been recommended by the
Faculty of Yale College and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees so when you hear these words
confer upon them these degrees that's
when you want to show the world how
excited you are to be graduating okay so
you just like do your thing shout out as
loud as you can so we're gonna practice
and again you know we're going to be
with all the professional schools
parents families on TV and everything
like that so so let's have a good
practice here so and again at the end of
these degrees they have been recommended
by the Faculty of Yale College and
approved by the corporation I now ask
you by your official act to confer upon
them these degrees
[Applause]
we'll try again I mean like these other
professional schools like they got
confetti going and they're just a lot
more boisterous so I think we're gonna
have to try this again one last time
and I'm facing president salivate and
I'll say they have been recommended by
the Faculty of Yale College and approved
by the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
okay that's much better yeah standing up
everything all that wave your flags
we'll look forward to it tomorrow
thank you brother Chun
we'll varsity athletes Andrea Masterson
and Simon Whiteman captains of the
cross-country and baseball teams please
come to the podium
[Applause]
Andrea you will go down in the books as
one of the all-time greats in Yale
women's cross country you are the Ivy
League heptagonal cross country
individual champion for 2018 a
three-time NCAA qualifier a two-time
NCAA all-region honors recipients and a
two-time Hyp cross country individual
champions in track and field you have
written your way onto the all-time list
in four events Andrea you have
accomplished all of this in your sport
at the same time you are majoring in
majoring in architecture as legend has
it one of the most time-consuming majors
at Yale it takes a special person to do
that we wish you luck on Thursday as you
will race at the NCAA first rounds in
Jacksonville Florida to qualify for the
NCAA finals for your superb
accomplishments as an athlete your
success in the classroom and your
leadership and for exemplifying in
yourself the commitment the hard work
and excellence of so many varsity
athletes at Yale Yale takes great pride
in presenting you one of the most
distinguished runners in Yale ruins
cross country history with the Nellie P
Elliott award
Simon you as well have been the captain
of your team a leader to whom others and
I look incoming to yell you move from
second base to shortstop and with very
hard work became what your head coach
says is the best shortstop he has ever
had in 27 years at Yale defensively your
play at shortstop help yell lead all
Division one baseball in double plays
per game in 2019 and the 2018 team said
an all-time Division one record for
field percentage as a hitter you are at
the top of the baseball lineup
incredibly you graduate with the second
most hits 213 and stolen bases 71 in the
entire 154 years of Yale baseball
history
this and your teammates effort led to
two Ivy League championships sports
media outlets predicts you to be a
professional baseball player and drafted
this June Simon you have done all of
this well guess what winning the Delaney
kippot Award for the highest grade point
average of any graduating senior varsity
student-athlete which is with a 3.97 GPA
in chemical engineering
your lowest grade in seven semesters
with an a-minus in freshman lab I bet
that professor feels bad in your junior
year you were the co recipient of one of
Yale's most prestigious prizes for an
undergraduate the frances gordon brown
prize an award also won by a former Yale
baseball great US President George HW
Bush for your incredible performance on
the field and in the classroom always
wearing a tie in class and for knocking
it out of the park in both areas
Yale takes enormous pride in awarding
you the William Neely Mallory award for
2019
[Applause]
congratulations to the both of you and
to the senior class of 2019
[Applause]
[Music]
ivana pike will you please come to the
stage and and Jonathan Salazar will you
please join Ivana the nakanishi prize is
awarded to two graduating seniors who
while maintaining high academic
achievement have provided exemplary
leadership in enhancing race or ethnic
relations at Yale College
this year's prizes are awarded to Alana
Pike of Timothy Dwight college and
Jonathan Salazar of Pauli Murray College
elana pike a molecular cellular and
developmental biology major hailing from
the Mohawk nation at agua sauce tea has
been described as a fearless leader of
the Native community known for her grace
dignity and strength she has served as
TV's big sub coordinator as a member of
the Student Advisory Committee to the
Center for the Study of race indigeneity
and transnational migration and as a
peer liaison for the Native American
cultural center community as president
and vice president of the Association of
Native Americans at Yale she has devoted
herself to supporting indigenous peoples
Day celebrations and the Ivy native
conference on indigenous feminism's
re-establishing the a powwow and
advocating from water protectors at
Standing Rock next year she will be
serving as a research scholar in the
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences at
Harvard as she prepares to apply to
doctoral programs for her remarkable
service and leadership Yale College is
honored to award the nakanishi Prize to
Alana pike
Jonathan Salazar an ethnicity race and
migration major has been described as a
leader friend and scholar arriving at
Yale as a second year student with an
acute understanding of what it was like
to be new at Yale and seeking connection
jonathan has had an outsized impact in
the many roles he has played he has
served as a peer liaison for La Casa
cultura
as a member of Ballet Folklorico Mehta
and La Casa senior Events Committee
Ana's one of the inaugural
first-generation low-income student
ambassadors this year he served as head
first-year counselor for Pauli Murray
College in all these roles he has
dedicated himself to making everyone
feel welcome connected and included
following graduation Jonathan will be
returning to New Mexico to work as a
paralegal while preparing for graduate
school for his extraordinary service in
leadership
Yale College is honored to award the
knock and easy prize to jonathan Salazar
[Applause]
juda la whoa will you please come up to
the stage the James Andrew Haas prize is
awarded annually to that member of the
senior class in Yale College whose
breadth of intellectual achievement
strength of character and fundamental
humanity shall be adjudged by the
faculty to a provided leadership for his
or her fellow students inspiring in them
a love of learning and concern for
others this year the Haas Prize is
awarded to Jew Jude of ROM awawa of
Branford College
[Music]
to the Lala graduates with distinction
in the global affairs major with a
second major in molecular cellular and
developmental biology and as a global
health studies scholar Jude is deeply
committed to providing health care to
vulnerable communities he is founder and
director of Saha wasallam a nonprofit
organization that provides humanitarian
assistance to Syrian refugees across the
Middle East as president of the Yale
Rotaract Club he has supported refugee
populations and local underserved
residents in New Haven he has
volunteered his time at the Haven free
clinic providing health services to
uninsured patients and teaching and
tutoring students in local schools as a
scholar Jude already has a list of
publications with articles in print and
forthcoming on cancer treatment in
displaced populations refugee health and
community health care he has received
multiple awards and fellowships in
support of his research and advocacy
including the Fulbright scholarship and
the Fox international fellowship next
year he will begin a master's of Public
Health at Cambridge University for his
dedication to public service at home and
abroad Yale College is proud to bestow
the James Andrew Haas Memorial Prize
upon jewel Jude arum Halawa
[Applause]
hi everyone I'm Jacqueline and I'm
Jonathan and we'll be introducing some
classy traditions beginning in 1851 each
graduating class has laid an ivy plant
somewhere on Yale's campus symbolizing
the enduring nature of the friendships
made in the past four years this year
our class IV will be placed right
outside of Phelps gate underneath a
stone carving of the cost of the year of
2019 for future generations who walk
through Phelps gates and enter Yale
College the ivy and the stone will be
symbols of the resilience and strength
our class found here now in the bag
underneath your chair you'll find a clay
pipe and some bubbles the pipe is known
as the churchwarden pipe and it's been
given to graduating seniors since 1869
needless to say if this were in 1869
plastic things would look a little
different we'd all be sitting in a big
circle wearing tweed jackets and smoking
tobacco out of these pipes now we sit
together on old campus wear funny hats
and blow bubbles still the tradition of
the church warden pipe hasn't heard for
nearly 150 years a lot of time has
passed and Yale no longer looks the way
once did the jelly's of now don't look
like the Yale use of the 1800s
but the planting of the ivy and the
churchwarden pipe are two traditions
that unite generation of Yale graduates
to speak more about change at Yale in
all its forms it is my pleasure to
introduce Larry Fulton and his class
reflection how to spot a Yalie
[Applause]
good afternoon doesn't look like I have
any notes up here
where's Mohammed oh hey that's my friend
Mohammad I'm gonna out him for a second
he thinks that he can spot a Yalie
anywhere he says I saw the Whiffenpoofs
in Beijing didn't he say that yeah you
did you did makes me wonder how did he
know that it was the woods how did he
know that it was the whiffs you know
maybe it was as easy as asking someone
there residential college what was their
favorite sandwich at Alpha Delta did
they take a class called the good life
and then get credit for it or is it
something else entirely that binds
jelly's together but but what is that
something and what is it what does it
have to do not just with everyone who's
here in the audience today but with the
thousands of jelly's who have occupied
this university before us there's been a
lot of change at Yale even in our four
years two new residential colleges
hopper freshmen are now first years
that's right yeah sorry JD sucks
especially freshmen are now first years
masters are heads of college next year
anyone can live in gender-neutral
housing if they so choose and audition
and audition for the Whiffenpoofs but
this really comes as no surprise I mean
yeah
has always been a place that's embraced
sharp differences in opinion where big
ideas have clashed we are after all the
school of John Ashcroft and John Kerry
Bill Buckley and Bill coffin we may have
been right or wrong left or right but we
most certainly have always been engaged
and it is through this clash this push
of ideas against each other at Yale that
change has been born at the height of
the Great Depression the SAT was
established to provide scholarships such
that more low-income students could
could attend universities like yay
then on campus Yale student body started
to challenge its workers too started to
challenge the university to pay its
workers more while alumni wrote letters
opposing pointless new law school
courses in economics and policy thirty
years later in 1969 Yale admitted its
first class of women it was that same
year that this campus erupted as a
battleground of the civil rights
movement for a year Black Panthers Bobby
Seale and Ericka Huggins stood trial in
New Haven
thousands of protesters flooded the
green and yet Yale president Kingman
Brewster insisted on opening campus
dining halls provided meals and students
provided housing to people who had come
to speak their truth then four years ago
yell admitted the class of 2019 its most
diverse class of students ever and the
times tried to act like we were Yale's
first rodeo I don't think so I think
that there has always been disagreement
and debate here what binds us as jelly's
isn't the specific controversies it's
the training and analytical thinking the
instruction to value empathy and
emotional intelligence and difference in
opinion it's learning from watching our
friends in scholarship end of the round
of music art theater architecture that
not everything that counts can be
counted while not all that can be
counted really counts and more than that
there is an ethos here a spirit of
acknowledgement among all those who may
disagree cliche as it may be jelly's
strive to engage in the world and to
make a difference
it's simply in the air here for me
that's yet this weird rowdy bunch of
kids from all over the world together in
one place committed to Lux at Veritas
and to each other who believed that they
can do anything in 1939 jelly's rich and
poor redefined the role of government
1969 jelly's male and female of all
colors held this country's legal system
accountable in 2019 now we are
inseparable isolationists undocumented
model citizens spiritual atheists stoic
revolutionaries tomboyish guys
presidential pre-meds
and it's anyone's guess how out of our
hundred contradictions legacy will
manifest one thing is certain
Yale is not naive in choosing a class
when this place has chosen to open its
doors to more of us to new types and new
breeds history has been made and this
time around they chose us they chose us
to engineer a solution to climate change
to keep destructive weapons out of the
wrong hands
they chose us to build an inclusive
world and which kids don't have to come
to a place like Yale for a fair chance
and an equal shot so with all of that I
repeated my question of Muhammad I asked
how could you spot the Whiffenpoofs
in Beijing and his answer was well Larry
they walk around in bowties fair enough
fair enough
some of us are pretty easy to spot from
the outside especially today I think
today is about what's in here speaking
of Dean Shawn president Sall Ave
esteemed faculty and staff loved ones
family members thank you for everything
you challenged us certainly but allowed
us to do the same throughout you were
firm in your values telling us that we'd
make it here through the tears the
anxieties the science and the writing
credits today is proof that together we
could make it and to my fellow graduates
and friends in the class of 2019 we were
accompanied here by a wave of change
then we elected an alder we found in
every vote counts we proved that some
people do have super powers and we
researched the world over because like
jelly's for many generations we don't
simply study history he spotter Yeley at
the edge of history making a difference
pushing the boundaries and leaving a
legacy here's to you class of 2019 for
the past four years and for their
lifetime commitment to service and to
humanity that we will carry with us out
into the broader world thank you and
congratulations
[Applause]
so here's how to spot a Yalie a Yalie is
a student who is more erudite and
eloquent than their Dean lily Sparrow
merfolk right we please come up to the
stage the Warren Memorial High
scholarship prize for the senior
majoring in the humanities who ranks
highest in scholarship is awarded this
year - Lilly sparrow Murph RA of
Davenport college Lilly is a fiercely
proud West Virginian and head first-year
counselor in Davenport college balancing
a double major in the history of science
medicine and public health and molecular
cellular and developmental biology she
was elected to Phi Beta Kappa in her
senior year and graduate summa [ __ ] laude
with distinction in both our majors even
as a first year student Lilly's
instructors commented on her unusual
sensitivity in dealing with challenging
material she brought that same
sensitivity to bear on her senior essay
which explores the history of Coal
Company physicians in Central Appalachia
she is also the recipient of the Y work
award in recognition of her outstanding
contributions as an undergraduate
employee in recognition of her
extraordinary achievements Yale College
is proud to award the Warren Memorial
High scholarship prize this year - Lilly
sparrow McCray
Hanna Lawrence will you please come up
to the stage the Russell Henry
Chittenden prize is awarded annually for
the senior majoring in the Natural
Sciences or in mathematics who ranks
highest in scholarship this year's prize
is awarded to Hannah Lewis Lawrence of
Davenport College Anna has distinguished
herself as a double major in applied
mathematics and computer science elected
to Phi Beta Kappa in her junior year
Hannah graduate summa [ __ ] laude with
distinction in both our majors in a
field that seldom changes answer keys
Hannah's senior project advisor in
applied mathematics states that she
offered a solution that is better than
what is known for this problem hannah
has balanced her extraordinary
performance in the classroom with her
passion for music playing as a devoted
member of the yeltsin four New York
Astros first violin section hannah has
also contributed her talents as a member
of the Yale College student advisory
committee on scientific and quantitative
reasoning advising the Yale College
Dean's office on matters related to
undergraduate education in recognition
of her commitment to academic excellence
Yale College proudly awards the Russell
Henry Chittenden Prize to Hannah
Louise Lawrence
Aaron obey an ache a pain can you please
come up to the stage the Lois Sadler
prizes for excellence in the Performing
and creative arts are awarded to two
outstanding seniors Aaron obey Aaron or
BAE is a writer whose work shows
intellectual rigor emotional depth and
stylistic grace while double majoring in
computer science and English with a
concentration in creative nonfiction
Iran has contributed 18 essays and
profiles to The New Yorker with topics
ranging from personal history to
contemporary photography to women's
gymnastics with courage and beauty his
creative thesis the basis of a planned
book length memoir addressed the impact
of a devastating family tragedy and
entailed travel to on Ankara Turkey the
reading of hundreds of pages of
dispositions legal transcripts and
police reports and profound
self-examination Iran graduates magna
[ __ ] laude a Phi Beta Kappa and with
distinction in both of his majors he
will pursue graduate studies in modern
Middle Eastern Studies at Oxford next
year as a Rhodes Scholar
[Applause]
Alexis ache a pain is an accomplished
dramatist with an astonishing promise a
double major in african-american studies
in English she graduates with
distinction in both and with a
concentration in playwriting and works
produced at the elder Matt and the Yale
playwrights Festival a Kay has trained
her fierce moral vision and finely tuned
ear on the fraud and authentic lives of
people in real places and in real
situations laying bare the urgent poetry
of voices that as she movingly insists
need to be heard her plays animate the
experiences and aspirations of people of
color in American history and her
mentors and professors note her works
deep compassion historical research and
political urgency in the fall a Kay
begins the MFA program in playwriting at
the Yale School of Drama for her
exceptionally compliment accomplishments
on the page and stage and for her bright
future ahead
Yale College is honored to award the
Lewis Adler prize for excellence in the
Performing and creative arts to ache a
pain
[Applause]
devyn Rigsby of Pearson college will he
please come up to the stage the Arthur
twining Hadley Prize which honors the
memory of the man who served as
president of Yale from 1899 to 1921 is
awarded annually to the senior in Yale
College majoring in to social sciences
who ranks highest in scholarship the
Alphaeus Henry snow prize is awarded to
that senior who through the combination
of intellectual achievement character
and personality shall be adjudged by the
faculty to have done the most for Yale
by inspiring in his or her classmates an
admiration and love for the best
traditions of high scholarship this year
both the Hadley and a snow prize are
awarded to Devon Christine Rigsby of
Pearson college
[Applause]
elected to Phi Beta Kappa in our junior
year seven Rigsby graduates summa [ __ ]
laude with distinction in her major
global affairs
Devon has been deeply involved in
research and leadership in global
affairs and Sciences she has been a US
Department of Education foreign language
and area studies fellow for Arabic and
in the Middle East as well as a fellow
for the peace and dialogue Leadership
Initiative she has also served as a
legislative intern for the state of
Illinois and as an intern in the
Egyptian consulate of Chicago and as an
extension of her work in the sciences
Devin has been a research assistant in
the Yale University School of Medicine
Department of Surgery and surgical
critical care Devan brings the same
rigor and excellence to the leadership
role she has held as president of Yale's
Phi Beta Kappa chapter and as an elected
representative of the Yale College
Council since its fall of 2015
filling the role of academic policy
director and chief of staff taken
together her accomplishments and her
fields of scholarship show extraordinary
promise as she prepares for a life of
service in global health policy and
refugee health care in the Arab world in
recognition of her contributions to her
fields of scholarship her love of
learning and her dedication to the
common good
Yale College is proud to award both the
Alphaeus Henry snow prize and the Arthur
twining Hadley prize to Devon Christine
Rigsby
[Applause]
hello everyone my name is Monty and I'm
in Elise and we're two members of the
class day committee before introducing
the next speakers we'd like to take a
moment to share to other class day
traditions first we wanted to introduce
you all to a very important tradition
that you will see tomorrow during
commencement during the commencement
procession the recipients of the top
five academic prizes that were just
awarded by Dean Sean Carey an official
flag or banner the winners of the warren
memorial prize russell henry Chittenden
prize arthur twining hadley prize
southern sadler prize and Alphaeus henry
snow prize carry the American flag
Connecticut flag Yale College banner
president's banner and Yale University
banner respectively second we'd like to
introduce you all to a very special item
that you will get to take home with you
seniors in your class day bags is a
booklet that contains reflections works
of art and poetry that capture our
shared Yale experience we call this the
2019 class anthology these pieces were
created by students administrators and
members of the faculty who wish to share
insights regarding our class our team
selected pieces that we found to be
exceptionally representative of our time
to your students both the happy
experiences and the more challenging
ones as the anthology team we went into
this project with the understanding that
there's no such thing as a singular Yale
experience we put together this
collection which encompasses a variety
of perspectives and we hope that you'll
take the time to read through it and
reflect on your own four years here you
might be surprised at the themes that
tie us together this year we've also
included several blank pages at the back
of the anthology feel free to use this
space for notes your own reflections or
classmates signatures our only request
is that you refrain from signing hag's
let's leave that in high school now it's
our pleasure to introduce the next
student speech which we promise will be
significantly funnier than any jokes we
just tried to make each year the class a
team selects one or more students to
provide a light-hearted
action on our nail experience this
year's speaker our Raffi Donna touch and
John Rosenberg their speech is entitled
vows to the class of 2019 please join us
in welcoming them to the podium
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
president salivate Dean Chun beloved
friends and families thank you for being
with us here today to the class of 2019
you did that you did the heck out of
that ok papers were written p-sets
were turned in a little late and you
didn't forget your advisers last name at
your Mellon form hey you in the back I
hope you're ready for the Pulitzer Prize
in radio journalism coming at you in the
next 10 to 12 years you in the front
boom founder and CEO of the next big
Fairtrade CBD cosmetics brand sitting in
front of us today is the next generation
of prolific writers and thinkers
captains of industry robber barons
you've all achieved so much and we're so
proud to call you our classmates and our
friends what if I'm not mistaken there's
a
a bit of an elephant in the quad if you
will okay John you do know the
expression is elephant in the room Rafi
I know I'm just trying to adapt that
idiom to campus life God okay anyways
I'm just gonna sort of take a moment to
embrace radical vulnerability right now
you know okay it's 2019 after all our
graduating year and I'm just gonna say
it
romantically I'm unfulfilled four years
of dating at Yale have been excruciating
ly painful it has been honestly the
military industrial complex of romance
nobody knows how it works
somebody is getting so freakin rich and
somebody's gonna get hurt
somebody's gonna get hurt it's dating in
the digital age the emotional apparatus
of the class of 2019 has been blown
apart by nuclear grade weaponry and at
an institution like Yale that is so
focused on success we just want to take
a second to acknowledge some of our
failures yeah I mean we've all been
stood up by a tinder date at Wesleyan
because she was preparing her fake dead
hermit crab for a fake burial yes this
actually happened and yes I'm still
upset about it we've all had a crush on
a TF I don't know I'm not like I don't
like thinking about anyone specifically
in this particular moment but maybe in
the contemporary art history class we
took sophomore spring in which we
accidentally and confidently said I love
you to them at the end of section how
did they say it back yeah we're actually
moving to Brooklyn together after
graduation
oh geez seriously obviously not I'm so
sorry and you know what I also want to
highlight I dynamic that we all missed
the boat on our personal librarians
right like
yeah they were the one person at this
university we could count on to respond
to us in a productive and healthy way
actually my personal librarian ghosted
me are you serious I told her that Orbis
Advanced Search was anything but an
intuitive user-friendly comprehensive
database and she refused to speak to me
again you know this conversation is
really opening up a deep well of
rejection frustration personal pain
honestly saying do you remember our very
first week on campus campy yell well I
can't fail marette will workshop that
anyway sue me but I was unpleasantly
surprised when I learned that walking on
to the football team didn't mean I could
just simply walk onto the field and be
welcomed by a brotherhood of strong
virile and playful men yeah I think we
all realized that Yale is guilty of some
pretty false advertising we arrive on
move-in day equipped with our twin excel
sheets ready to take risks and explore
all of the amazing opportunities we were
promised little do we know that to work
in a college buttery you have to have
earned a Michelin star and I'm just like
I know how to put a dino nugget in a
microwave yeah to get accepted into
professor and Fadiman illustrious
writing seminar writing about oneself
you have to have literally written Moby
Dick and because the class is on memoir
you have to have been a sperm whale
and speaking of whales in high school we
were big fish in small ponds then we
came to Yale we figured out that we were
actually small fish on a really big
football team I'll say it being
gainfully enrolled at this university
can be stressful and the way Yale E's
deal with stress is honestly kind of
unhinged yeah I think it'd be good for
us all to recognize naked parties as one
of the most bizarre high-maintenance not
low-key traditions in the history of
human traditions fight it's John from
daily themes I'm not wearing any clothes
either how are you I'm incredibly
anxious we are aware that there are
parents in the audience we are also
aware that some of you may have met at
Yale and we hate that yep really really
not cool guys the expectation of finding
your spouse at Yale is way too much
pressure and not the point I'm trying to
write a 5 to 8 pager on inflation in the
buy more republic all right I can't be
bothered to think about raising a family
yeah I'm just trying to intentionally
and thoughtfully utilize my Durfee swipe
I have an absolutely no place to get
married some of us will end up marrying
someone in our fro quelle group well not
because seriously college is weird
they throw some of the fifth floor of
l-dub there it is there it is and and
now all of a sudden we have to wear
flip-flops in the shower for legitimate
health concerns and and we're expected
to find our soul mates and my Dean is
seriously trying to tell me that that
doesn't fulfill my social science
distribution requirement Rafi is credit
deficient and will be returning in the
fall that is not incorrect well I think
we can all safely say that we gave
dating in the digital age the old
college try
even though college has not yielded me
my life partner I am graduating right
now with some practice taking care of
the people I love yeah I mean talk about
in sickness and in health you should
have seen my roommate go for Grey's
Anatomy when I got streptococcal
pharyngitis
you mean strep throat yeah that's what I
said
streptococcal pharyngitis although we're
leaving campus and dispersing all over
the world the bottom line is till death
do us part
Yale class of 2019 this is pretty
difficult first to communicate but we've
actually had feelings for you for kind
of a long time we didn't want to say
anything in case it like interfered with
this amazing friendship thing we've got
going but there's no point pretending
right now you're the one that got away
do you want to get a meal or go to the U
AG on Saturday morning we actually kind
of have incredible chemistry I feel like
this is getting kind of serious are we
exclusive or do you want to meet my
parents they'll pay for dinner I think
we should move in together let's start
with a beta fish-- and then we can
consider getting a dog I just feel like
you're not listening to me I'm not
willing to give up on us I can't hold
this in any longer will you marry me I
love you more now than I've ever loved
you before you look so beautiful in
white I can't believe we're having twins
Yale will name them Benjamin and
Franklin 2019 now I wouldn't want to
grow old with anyone else and I wouldn't
want to graduate with anyone else
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello class of 2019 I'm Sonny Stevens
I'm Maya Rodriguez and I'm Nick Gerard
we would like to share one final set of
class state traditions and then
introduce our final student speaker the
class reflections are legacies of days
when Yale students delivered formal
academic speeches during the ceremony
today we carry on this tradition with
two short sets of remarks about the Yale
experience I you heard from Larry Fulton
Rafi Dona touch and John rosin blew
speaker's audition before the class
State Committee and I selected based on
how their pieces reflect our four years
speeches that show our resilience and
grit but also that show our ability to
have fun alongside these reflections the
class history has taken many forms over
the years to tell the story of our time
at Yale in keeping up with modern
technology and with the intent to
provide as much student input into the
class history as possible during the
singing of bright College years you will
see a curation of photos that the class
of 2019 has submitted to be displayed
before us right College years was
written in 1881 by Henry Durand and has
been the unofficial of alma munna fishel
alma mater of Yale sense Summit reunions
football games in class day it remains a
symbol of Yale's traditions in long long
history on the last lines of your song
we raise our handkerchiefs if you lost
yours from freshman year Yale Alumni
Association has generously provided new
ones and waved them along as years of
graduating classes have before us
singing for God for country and for you
the original Ivy ode for the class of
1852 composed in Latin sapphic stanzas
described a symbolic connection between
the growth of the ivy vine and the
flourishing of the graduating class
Latin verse has given way to an original
spoken word or lyrical performance by
member of the graduating class but the
purpose remains the same the
long-forgotten second verse of bright
college years describes how just as the
Ivy twines around the oak so too are our
hearts bound to Yale by ties of love The
Ivy ode is a message of resilience
and flourishing a celebration of who we
have been at Yale and the lifetime ahead
as graduates of this university the 2019
Ivy ode entitled all our names is
written and will be delivered by a Shia
Ajani bright bright college years will
immediately follow
please welcome Ashiya
[Applause]
the first time we walked on this campus
the gates cried open and welcomed our
eager smiles youthful exuberance
breathing life into these archaic walls
many of us perfected our elevator
pitches during foot or cultural
connections some combed through
Quinnipiac soil during harvest learned
how to say welcome in five different
languages during oh is focused on who
makes New Haven great and when we all
came for orientation the world melted
into an oasis unfamiliar to many a voice
said this can be your home too and we
readily accepted and this is no easy
task home building this creation will
ask you to bare your soul to view
yourself in new ways unexplored and
unimaginable and we rose to the task
someone put flowers in your hair during
Spring Fling and told you you were
beautiful finally you had a professor
who looked like you who reminded you why
you came to this campus you want a mock
trial tournament you got your heart
broken
you wrote an angry love poem you weren't
you finally told off that one arrogant
person in seminar you were unwittingly
that one arrogant person in seminar you
shed a dead name and honored the right
version of yourself with correct
pronouns and a new vibrant shade of
lipstick you helped put on a drag show
you watch too many movies in one sitting
and debated with your suitemates whether
or not Zootopia was an allegory for the
police state into the slanted hours of
the night all while smiling and falling
deeper in love with a place so seemingly
unfamiliar how the years asked us to
consider ourselves what has changed
since those first days how our eyes and
hearts have softened how we have grown
into even better versions of ourselves
and that does not come without this
responsibility to one another what will
we make of ourselves beyond these bright
college years in her poem the summer day
the late American poet Mary Oliver takes
the time to observe and reflect Ponder's
the ground
hopper asked who made her and this poem
Oliver asks what we plan to do with our
one wild and precious life Oliver does
not demand that we bleed ourselves dry
searching for adventure but that we
marvel at the many steps we have taken
to get here and the ones that will come
after class of 2019
will you let this world know your name
in all of its iterations will you take
time to ponder the grasshopper when the
evils of this world tempt us into apathy
and ignorance will you remember the love
that you found here the love that made
you ask more and demanded that you never
give up this fight the love born from
newness through laughter through song
through chant and protest and resilience
what love have you carried from all of
your different homes to this new
northeastern one on that one night you
know the one where your hope had faded
into almost nothing and the dust asked
more of you than you could bear a pretty
girl brought you Bova and said do not go
quietly think of the dawn and all the
hands that pushed you towards this
moment think of the ways we were not
kind o we were kind not only to others
but to ourselves we carriers of light
and truth leave our mark wherever we go
when the gates closed and our time here
has drawn its last breath
what will this campus remember you by
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations everyone class day is
now completed made it then just so much
for coming and have a wonderful evening
[Applause]
[Music]